i must say
it's not no surprise that you and i
would agree on this but yeah the right
cure for uh obnoxious speech is to let
it be aired so people can see what it
actually is and yeah
unfortunately you know it's very clear
that this era in which
um censorship is back with a vengeance
uh is also an era in which we are losing
agreement on the most basic stuff you
know whether or not
two plus two equals four whether or not
men and women are different like we we
have lost
the ability to agree on anything and i
think people do not fully appreciate the
danger of that
yeah no i it it worries me
um and yeah i remember when people were
saying
oh well you know when these students get
to the real world
that'll straighten them out and we're
definitely saying from the very
beginning it's like well no if there's
enough of them they'll change the real
world into a very strange place
and what's what drives me nuts is that i
hate and i have people who are in charge
of um all sorts of different companies
come to us
and say it's like listen we've got a
crop from this elite
school or these elite schools and it's
dysfunctional
like things that used to be just
interpersonal tensions have turned into
immediately going to human resources and
then like almost complete
parallelization of some organizations
but they always say
but you can't say what's what
organization this is um but it's going
to bring
it's going to bring organizations down
it probably already has
you know what happened at the um at the
new york times with james bennett that
was absolutely this dynamic you know
definitely there were older
uh older people as well who were against
him but the whole dynamic of just the
um you know if it's if we can call you
make a strong argument that somehow this
is
and of course they rhetorically use the
this is threatening our lives
argument which is the ultimate
rhetorical uh card you can play
to get rid of a uh editor who was
specifically hired to try to rock the
boat back in 2016. um
it's this summer i hope that i feel
like the fever's starting to break a
little bit at least this current fever
and that maybe things aren't as
illiberal and scary as they were maybe
in say august
um but it's gonna come back uh at some
point if we don't do
something about it well it's going to
come back and a lot is
riding on the election and it's not
clear that either
path actually addresses the issue but
um so
it's interesting that you see it as
possibly the fever having broken i
certainly
hope that's the case i think we're in a
great deal of danger but we uh we
we are just i i feel like there is at
least um
some amount of pushback that i'm seeing
where people aren't immediately getting
fired for saying
you know what would have once been
considered mildly controversial stuff
yeah so you said it's going to bring
down institutions
i think if anything you're being too
cautious that
at some level the game theory is very
very clear and
to the extent that you have different
if you had universities with different
commitments to wokeness
those that were woke would fail because
they would be producing inferior
graduates who were
less capable of thinking clearly about
all the things that college is supposed
to arm you
to think about but when every college
does it the point is
everything downstream of those colleges
is going to suffer those flaws which
means
that the private sector firms that
depend on those graduates
will be hobbled relative to any
presumably foreign competitors that
aren't
similarly hobbled so effectively you're
looking at everything
um at the higher scales being
jeopardized simultaneously which
ultimately means the nation will be uh
rendered and capable of fending off its
competitors abroad which could
restructure the way the whole planet
functions and frankly it could
restructure
the level of commitment to liberty that
the planet has because
the u.s has been bedrock to that
commitment to liberty yeah that's really
funny you should say that because
that's exactly one of the things i'm
working on an article about right now
about how
just by having an increasing incidence
of actual
you know papers being withdrawn and and
research really being seriously caught
into question
at a time when higher education is
already there's already a lot of
skepticism about it because people are
realizing
they can do this stuff online they can
do this they can do they can do the
stuff at home and it's ridiculously
expensive
why not do it in other places and i
think that the um
the the the downstream effects of
american higher education turning into
something of a laughingstock you know
globally will have
very dire results for um the commit the
the
uh the community um the educational
community
and and we'll be on of course and well
beyond because at some level
even if you acknowledge as you and i
both did at the top of this discussion
that there is uh plenty of inequity
in the u.s and that it is not evenly
distributed the fact is
killing the goose that lays the golden
eggs even if those golden eggs are not
evenly distributed is going to be a loss
for everyone and you know who's going to
lose
worst are the most downtrodden people
the people who
get the shaft every time so um yeah this
is an
incredibly foolish squandering of the
power and position that we have
and it's not going to create a better
world for
anybody downstream of it yeah no i i
i i am worried to say the least and i
got a two
two year old and a four-year-old which
makes me all the more uh
paranoid yes although that's young
enough
that maybe the dust will have settled
and we'll be on to something
smarter than this by the time you need
to send them into the world
well if something can't continue the way
it's going it won't
yeah well that's uh yeah it's a very
frightening thing you've just said
but
[Music]